[Music]
our series a more perfect union Ames's
showed that what unites us is Americans
is far greater than what divides us
millions of students across the country
will return to school this week after
the holidays so we're looking at a
program that brings a special kind of
love and encouragement into classrooms
than needed Jan Crawford is in
Washington where grandparents are part
of the lesson plan Jan good morning
welcome artists so you know I mean maybe
the only thing as powerful as that
parents love is a grandparents love and
it schools across the country more than
20,000 seniors are volunteering every
day S Foster Grandparents right there in
the classroom as the day begins at Excel
public school in Southeast Washington
there are a few mature faces among the
young girls rushing to class wearing
blue aprons and serving up hugs or six
foster grandmother's working alongside
the school's teachers to help students
succeed inside dr. Smith's first-grade
class is Grandma Margie Dixon what does
it mean to you to be here because the
difference does she make it school time
they're role models for our young ladies
principal Taniya Pritchard said she'd
love a grandparent in every classroom
our grandmother's live in the community
so they see our young ladies at the
grocery store on the buses and so the
girls when they're at home and in their
communities and with their families they
can see a part of school for grandmas
Dixon Wanda Brookings and marine Brooks
the word that best describes their
experience is joy but it's a joy to get
up every morning knowing that a smile
and a hug is waiting for me who wouldn't
want to get up and get that they need
they need me and I need them each and
every day do you feel like you're really
helping them learn yes you see it every
day little things I do with my children
in the room I have one little girl I
didn't wink I did I say then that lets
her know you're doing good today
encouragement like a a wink and a
thumbs-up that's all secret the program
is only open to seniors earning less
than twice the federal poverty level
nationwide the Corporation for National
community service helps more than a
hundred and fifty thousand young people
work with 22,000 Foster Grandparents in
nearly every state the most important
factor to move people into
self-sufficiency is education cherrylle
Christmas runs the DC program one of the
largest in the country tried to match
individuals in areas and in schools and
early childhood that people are
struggling the kids benefit from the
social emotional connection and then for
the grandparents they too are learning
seniors get help with everything from
wills to annual physicals a recent study
found that nearly half of the program's
volunteers report improved health after
just one year something grandma marine
has felt personally what the doctors say
about you doing oh they told me to keep
up the good work my pressure down your
blood pressure's down go push it down
my weight is down I just had my
cataracts removed they're fine dice I
got to see my baby
but for these grandmother's the
program's most valuable benefit is in
the classroom yeah I had one book girl
to tell me she said do you know how much
I love you you know how you turn your
eyes because you have tears and yeah I
said you just don't know how much I love
you today baby but you're getting
emotional about this you see so many
children they don't get love they have
no idea what love is about it and to me
to share my love that can take them a
long ways
now the grandparents do get a small
stipend but of course the value goes far
beyond money for them here in Washington
there is a waiting list of a hundred
seniors who are hoping to get involved
the only hurdle more funding for the
program Anthony Don Jim thank you I love
those three ladies yeah find the funding
I mean it's great for the grandma that's
great for the kids yeah great for the
teachers to get help in the classroom
absolutely all right